♪ ♪
>> THE PROCESS FOR THE
BACKGROUND WAS ONGOING, AND THE
WHITE HOUSE HAD NOT RECEIVED ANY
SPECIFIC PAPERS REGARDING THE
COMPLETION OF THAT BACKGROUND
CHECK.
>> THE FBI SUBMITTED A PARTIAL
REPORT ON THE INVESTIGATION IN
QUESTION IN MARCH, AND THEN A
COMPLETED BACKGROUND
INVESTIGATION IN LATE JULY THAT,
SOON THEREAFTER, WE RECEIVED A
REQUEST FOR FOLLOW-UP INQUIRY,
AND WE DID THE FOLLOW-UP AND
PROVIDED THAT INFORMATION IN
NOVEMBER, AND THEN WE
ADMINISTRATIVELY CLOSED THE FILE
IN JANUARY, AND THEN EARLIER
THIS MONTH, WE RECEIVED SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION AND WE
PASS THAT ON AS WELL.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE PERSONNEL
SECURITY OFFICE, RECEIVED
INFORMATION ON WHAT THEY
CONSIDERED TO BE THE FINAL
BACKGROUND INVESTIGATION REPORT
IN NOVEMBER.
>> Bret: THE WHITE HOUSE
TRYING TO STRAIGHTEN OUT THIS
TIMELINE ABOUT ROB PORTER AT THE
ALLEGATIONS OF ABUSE WHEN
EVERYONE KNEW IT HERE AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
AND THE TIMELINE OF EVENTS PRIOR
TO THE RESIGNATION LAST WEEK.
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"
CATCHING UP WITH THE WHITE HOUSE
CHIEF OF STAFF ASKED ON MONDAY
IF THE WHITE HOUSE SHOULD HAVE
HANDLED MR. PORTER'S SITUATION
ANY DIFFERENTLY.
THE.
CHIEF OF STAFF JOHN KELLY SAID,
"NO, IT WAS ALL DONE RIGHT" BE
THE FIRST PERSON THAT KELLY
FIRED BACK IN JULY, ANTHONY
SCARAMUCCI, SO THIS ON TWITTER.
"WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF
JOHN KELLY ALMOST CERTAINLY KNEW
ABOUT CRIMINAL ALLEGATIONS OF
DOMESTIC ARAB NUMERIC ABUSE,
THEN RECENTLY FORCED OTHERS TO
LIE ABOUT THAT
TIMELINE, INEXCUSABLE, KELLY
MUST RESIGN.
THAT IS WHERE WE ARE TONIGHT AT
THE WHITE HOUSE.
CHARLES HURT, OPINION EDITOR FOR
"THE WASHINGTON TIMES."
CHARLES LANE, OPINION WRITER FOR
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
AND OLIVIER KNOX, YAHOO NEWS.
YOU HAD BEEN DEALING WITH THIS
TIMELINE, THEY ARE TRYING TO
STRAIGHTEN IT OUT, LIKELY WE ARE
GOING TO HEAR FROM JOHN KELLY,
YOU THINK?
>> TYPICALLY FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE, DAMAGE CONTROL,
THEY HAVE TO PUT THE PERSON IN
CHARGE IN THE ROOM, WHETHER THAT
IS THE CHIEF OF STAFF, KELLY, OR
DON McGAHN.
>> Bret: PROBABLY NOT
PRESIDENT TRUMP?
>> THIS IS A QUESTION THAT FALLS
MORE MUCH UNDER THE PURVIEW
UNDER THE CHIEF OF STAFF.
AND PAST ADMINISTRATIONS, THEY
HAVE SUFFERED THROUGH THAT BY
ASKING ABOUT SOME VERY
PENETRATING QUESTIONS.
WE DON'T KNOW IF THAT HAPPENED
IN THIS CASE.
>> Bret: CHARLIE HURT, WHEN
YOU LOOK AT WHAT THE FBI
DIRECTOR SAID AND THEN YOU HEAR
ABOUT THE FOCUS ON THE
WHITE HOUSE SECURITY OFFICE,
WHICH WAS KIND OF THE LINE TODAY
AS OPPOSED TO MONDAY, WHAT DO
YOU THINK, AND WHAT IS THE STORY
GO?
>> WELL, TO BE SURE, CHRISTOPHER
WRAY TODAY DID NOT PROVIDE ANY
COVER TO THE WHITE HOUSE ON THIS
SITUATION, BUT UNDER THIS
PRESIDENCY, I WOULD ALSO SAY
THAT IS PROBABLY THE LEAST
SHOCKING BREAK BETWEEN THE FBI
AND THIS WHITE HOUSE OF THE PAST
YEAR.
BUT THAT SAID, THIS DEBATE ABOUT
WHETHER THE INFORMATION REACHED
THE WHITE HOUSE OR REACH THE
PERSONNEL SECURITY OFFICE ACROSS
THE STREET, IT KIND OF DOESN'T
REALLY MATTER.
EXTREME INCURIOUSNESS ABOUT THIS
IS A PROBLEM IN AND OF ITSELF,
BUT IF YOU READ BETWEEN THE
LINES, THE WHITE HOUSE IS GOING
TO PLAY DEFENSE ON THIS.
BUT SARAH SANDERS HAS ADMITTED
THAT THEY HANDLED IT WRONG, THAT
THEY WISHED THEY HAD HANDLED IT
BETTER, AND THAT IS PROBABLY
WHERE THEY STAND.
>> Bret: CHUCK, HOW MUCH DO
YOU THINK IS ABOUT THIS OUT FOR
LONG NODS OUT FOR KELLY?
YOU SEE THIS, OUT TO USE CHRIS
WRAY'S INFORMATION, MAKES IT
CLEAR THAT THE KELLY COVER-UP IS
UNRAVELING ONE WHITE HOUSE
OFFICIAL SAYS, UNDER THE COVER
OF ANONYMITY.
>> OF COURSE, NOT UNDER THE
COVER OF ANONYMITY, THE MOOCH,
SCARAMUCCI, GETTING THAT, THERE
HAS ALWAYS BEEN A LOT OF
FACTIONALISM IN EVERY
WHITE HOUSE, THIS ONE HAS A
PARTICULAR PROBLEM FOR
JOHN KELLY.
HE WAS THE GUY WHO WAS SUPPOSED
TO PUT AN END TO ALL OF THAT.
HE WAS THE GENERAL WHO IS GOING
TO BE STABILIZING THIS
WHITE HOUSE.
FOR A WHILE, HE SEEMS TO BE
DOING THAT, BUT NOW THAT IS WHAT
IS DANGEROUS ABOUT THIS UPROAR
OVER HIS MISHANDLING OF PORTER
PORTER'S -- THE TERRIBLE
ALLEGATION AGAINST PORTER.
EITHER BY ACCIDENT OR DESIGN, IT
SEEMS TO BE DISABLING THE
WHITE HOUSE ALL OVER AGAIN.
THE BIG POLITICAL SELLING POINT
BEHIND HIS TENURE NOW DOESN'T
LOOK SO STRONG.
>> Bret: OLIVIER, I GUESS THE
REASON I GOT SO MUCH ATTENTION,
IT IS SO HEINOUS.
IT CHANGE THE WHOLE DYNAMIC.
>> THE FIRST ONE IS THE
UNDERLYING ALLEGED ACTS, PRETTY
HORRIFYING PAIN THE HUGE BRUISE
ON THE FACE OF ONE OF THE
EX-WIVES.
ALSO THIS SHIFTING EXPLANATION
FOR HOW THEY HANDLED THE
BACKGROUND CHECK, AND IF THERE
IS, THEY COULD REACH OTHER
PLACES IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
JARED KUSHNER'S LAWYER IS ON THE
RECORD AS SAYING THAT 12 PEOPLE
AT JARED KUSHNER'S LEVEL AND
JARED KUSHNER ALSO DON'T HAVE
SECURITY CLEARANCES, POTENTIALLY
ONLY IN ITS INFANCY.
>> IF JARED KUSHNER DIDN'T HAVE
THE SECURITY CLEARANCE AND CAME
BACK FROM THE FBI SAYING THEY
COULDN'T GET HIM TO HAVE THE
FULL SECURITY CLEARANCE, IS THAT
A POSSIBLE REASON THAT ROB
PORTER IS ALSO IN THIS LIMBO AND
LEFT THAT WAY, EVEN CONSIDERING
THIS ALLEGATION?
>> THIS IS WHAT THE LAWYER HAS
TOLD THE NEWS OUTLETS NOW, IN
SAYING THAT THE REASON THAT THIS
BACKGROUND CHECK -- WE DON'T
KNOW WHERE IT IS.
WE NOW HAVE THIS SKETCH FOR
ROB PORTER.
WE DON'T KNOW WHERE THE
QUESTIONER PROCESS IS AT ALL.
-- THE KUSHNER PROCESS IS THATI
-- THE KUSHNER PROCESS IS THATT
ALL.
THEY WERE CALLING FRIENDS AND
FAMILY OUT IN FRANCE.
>> Bret: HARD TO BELIEVE YOU
GOT ONE.
CHARLIE HURT, LASTING, THE
HEARING WAS ABOUT THREATS, THE
INTEL CHIEFS, YOU HAD DAN COATS
TALKING ABOUT THE NATIONAL
THREAT WHILE THE ADMINISTRATION
IS DEALING WITH THIS.
>> I AM CONCERNED THAT ARE
INCREASINGLY IN FRACTIOUS
POLITICAL, POLITICALLY WITH
RESPECT TO POLITICAL SPENDING,
IS THREATENING OUR ABILITY TO
DEFEND OUR NATION, BOTH IN THE
SHORT-TERM AN END ESPECIALLY IN
THE LONG TERM.
THIS SITUATION IS UNSUSTAINABLE,
AS I THINK WE ALL KNOW, AND
REPRESENTS A DIRE THREAT TO OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY.
>> Bret: WE HEARD SOMETHING
SIMILAR FROM MIKE MULLEN.
THIS HAPPENS NOT IN A BUBBLE.
IT HAPPENS AS THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS DEALING WITH
THIS BUDGET AND HOUSE SPEAKER
PAUL RYAN IS TALKING ABOUT HOW
TO DEAL WITH DEFICITS DOWN THE
ROAD.
IT SEEMS TO BE A BIG DEAL.
>> AS HE POINTED OUT, WE HAVE
HEARD THIS BEFORE.
IT IS THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
OUT OF THE HEARING TODAY.
BASICALLY WHAT HE IS SAYING IS,
IF WE WERE FACED WITH ANOTHER
9/11 SITUATION OR A COMPLETELY
DISSIMILAR, UNRELATED SITUATION
WE HAD TO RESPOND AND GO TO WAR
AND SPEND THE KIND OF MONEY WE
SPENT IN THE IRAQ WAR, WE COULD
NOT AFFORD TO DO IT BECAUSE OF
THAT DEBT, LET ALONE THE IDEA
THAT A LOT OF OUR ADVERSARIES,
LIKE CHINA, OWN ENORMOUS AMOUNTS
OF OUR DEBT, AND IF THEY WANTED
TO CRIPPLE OUR ECONOMY, THEY
COULD DO IT VERY QUICKLY.